[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens alors déjà je trouve
certaines lignes sont bien comme la 14
moderne rapide traire il en pense quoi
mon frère il aime pas moi j'aime j'aime
le métro pour ça parce qu'il ya un côté
social
sait on est ouverts en fait en nous
parlant qu'on a rien à voir si on
regarde après l'avoir et empêche pas de
discuter de balic filoche salue un
massif pour perdre assure lutte ciao
j'ai fait le choix il ya longtemps de
pavant une bagnole bus métro même un
budget pour le taxi dans l'année et
votre file en pense quoi bon faire
m'enfin c'est pourquoi pour la télé
française
amaga sonné comment vous dites
marveaux laisse en français il ya des
supers phoques dans le métro souvent les
animaux aquatiques quoi tend pas travaux
est toujours en panne et votre frère il
en pense quoi
ah ça je ne sais pas il faut lui
demander
c'est qu'on prend le je les prends que à
marriott mois les transports en commun
un chapeau ça va mon pote je me sauve et
oui là c'était le bordel a dit y
abordait la peux te dire ça mord pas là
c'est pas en quoi parce qu'à ici te dire
à la fois c'est une galère j'arrêtais à
côté là bas c'était un bordel ça vaut
quoi
j'ai en double file je suis content je
suis juste après ben je pensais pas de
froisser le fils d'anna et de georges
pernoud virus on te l'a trouvé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]